(engine revving)
- Hit it.
- Let's fucking crush this!
- [Keith & Chris] Chicken Watch!
(upbeat techno music)
(chicken squawk)
- [Chris] It was a dish that
was based out of revenge.
Ghost pepper is used to deter elephants.
(excited whoops)
I burned myself.
(romantic piano music)
This is about love.
- [Keith] Is there something
going on between us?
Maybe you shouldn't be here?
(cymbal crash)
(guitar beats)
- [Chris] Chicken raps?
(silence)
- Oh, chicken raps!
- Yeah, like rapping.
(record scratch)
- [Chris] What time is it? Check your--.
- [Keith] Chicken Watch.
- [Keith] Ch-ch-chicken Watch.
- What time is it?
Check your--
- [Keith] Watch.
- [Chris] Check your--
- Ch-ch-chicken watch.
2k18.
(yelling)
- Oh, chicken watch.
♪ Straight outta Nashville, ♪
♪ we feeling good, ♪
♪ eatin' so much chicken
like you knew we would. ♪
♪ It's crazy, it's crazy,
it's heating us up, ♪
♪ and we're having lots of
milk in a plastic cup. ♪
♪ And we're feelin' really good
now, feelin' really high, ♪
♪ feelin' like we're gonna
reach up to the sky. ♪
♪ Feeling all depressed and
all like we're gonna die. ♪
♪ Oh, we the fried chicken guys! ♪